Speaker 1: Let's go next to Matt from Arizona.
Things are pretty hectic in Arizona, I must say
that between the Kerry Lake situation,
Blake Masters, it's wacky down there.
Matt from Arizona, welcome.
Speaker 4:
That's exactly what they didn't talk
about. Me and my way of talking about
that yesterday.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Well, go ahead. What's going on?
Speaker 4: Oh. And my daughter is
screaming in my ears. I'm cool.
Speaker 1:
You are on the air. Matt, I don't know if
you had anything you wanted to say or ask.
Speaker 4: Okay. Well, just just the same thing.
You know, Kerry, like, I can't even understand how
people are even wanting to vote for her based upon
abortion rights. That's me and my wife's probably
biggest thing, just because that's kind of the
biggest thing in Arizona right now. Do and do.
Speaker 1: You ever have you met people
in person where they say, I like Kerry,
like I'm supporting her?
Speaker 6: No.
Speaker 4: You have not. I don't even think. I
don't. I don't hang out with those type of people.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. Well, but how do you know
not to hang out with them unless they mention it?
Speaker 4: Or you say they go, I'm so sorry.
Speaker 1: Listen, it sounds like
you got a lot going on there, man.
Speaker 4: Yeah, you understand? All right.
Speaker 1: I'll let you go. Yeah, it
sounds crazy. It sounds like you're
careful with those diaper blowouts. Okay,
very, very careful. They could be lethal.